in this morning Saturday session Elvis
Costello Rolling Stone says his first
new album in five years finds him
squaring his restless artistic impulses
with his storied past here's our
conversation about that and more
followed by a special performance with
his band the imposters in 40 years of
making music Elvis Costello has often
collaborated across jaws with fellow
Liverpudlian Paul McCartney with Burt
Bacharach
[Music]
and with Questlove and the roof you have
never been afraid to sort of take a
detour and and and look at a certain
kind of music that a lot of people don't
associate with you sometimes it
horrifies people when it's very far from
what they see as home or your strong
point but what about the people that
embrace the the different thing you did
and found that the first thing that they
could appreciate it
on look now he's back with Burt
Bacharach
god
who he's been riding with for 20 years
the album includes three songs from a
Bacharach castello musical yet to be
produced
sometimes I lead the way sometimes he
leads the way sometimes the music is
entirely is in the case of the song
stripping paper which was intended for
this show I wrote all of the music and
sent it to him said Burt do you want to
try and add sign to this he said no this
song is finished so that's pretty good
compliment as you don't get much better
than that don't really get better than
that good
Elvis also has an old song he wrote with
Carole King on the record
I was on tour with Bob Dylan in 1995 and
I got the last Shawn Dublin and Carole
King's in the band
oh we wrote this song Costello is back
on tour after taking a sudden break last
summer canceling dates after surgery to
remove a small but very aggressive
cancerous malignancy how's your health
I'm great
you are yeah yeah I was extremely lucky
to have this little thing found but it
got complicated when British tabloids
blew it up into a life-threatening
cancer scare those answering letters for
three weeks you know no I am NOT dying
but you know it's not to make a joke of
it understand you not have to walk very
far to find somebody who you love who's
genuinely having a fight you fell it was
disrespectful to the people who really
are battle yeah answer yeah and on his
new album Elvis's voice sounds stronger
than ever
[Applause]
the you actually in the beginning didn't
think of yourself as a singer no not a
root not originally one of my favorite
songwriters of my teenage years was
Robbie Robertson he didn't sing in the
band he was the main righty and yet
there were three people in the band that
sang I just couldn't find a Rick Danko
no Richard Manuel and I live on him to
play with so I had to do the singing
myself everybody took a step back and I
was just left there like the volunteer
you know now on a special Saturday
session recorded live just for us before
he show at the Paramount Theater in
Asbury Park New Jersey with that song
co-written with Carole King here is
Elvis Costello and the imposters